replicating application data is an
important component to using site
recovery manager
i'm darren schmitz with vmware and in
this fourth video of the series i'll be
showing the initial configuration of
vsphere replication in my google cloud
vmware engine private cloud
starting new replications can be
initiated from the site recovery user
interface by clicking on new
if there are business requirements that
require dedicating a replication server
to one or more applications it can be
done from this screen
the next task is to select the virtual
machines that need to be replicated for
the application
in this example perhaps ubuntu 0 0 1 2
and 3 belong to the application that
needs to be protected
the data store and policies can be
selected on the target bringing us to
the replication settings screen
the first option is selecting the
recovery point objective
the slider can be adjusted between 5
minutes and 24 hours
the point in time instances are
replication checkpoints that will be
converted to snapshots during a recovery
the default is three instances that will
be kept for five days and each virtual
machine can have up to 24.
if vmware tools is installed on the
guests os quiescent can help ensure that
in-flight i o is flush to disk but may
increase rpo times
network compression can reduce bandwidth
and encryption can protect the data but
both come at the cost of some cpu
resources and potentially a higher rpo
the replication wizard will also offer
to create a protection group for the
virtual machine selected
a protection group can be thought of as
a boundary for virtual machines that
need to fail or be migrated together due
to interdependencies
a recovery plan for the application can
also be created at this point in the
process whereas any additional
modifications to the plan will need to
be adjusted later
once the details have been verified
clicking finish will start the
replications
[Music]
each replication's progress can be
tracked by periodically clicking the
refresh button while we wait for the
data to be replicated to the other
google cloud vmware engine region let's
look at the protection groups and
recovery plans that were just created
the protection group summary shows the
number of virtual machines protected the
names of the virtual machines and the
recovery plans that the protection group
belongs to
the recovery plans page is where the
plan specifics can be customized for
this application
more on this in the next video
flipping back to check on the
replications once all the data has been
replicated to the opposite site a green
status check mark indicates that the
replication is okay and the data is now
protected
customizing the recovery plan performing
a test and migrating the application
will be shown in the next video in the
series
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
vmware dash cloud.google.com
[Music]